guys I just got back from a hinge date
why am I doing this to myself so we
scheduled to go to dinner we are sitting
at the restaurant seems very nice not a
catfish things are going well and the
waitress comes over to a sticker order
and I said okay I'm gonna take the
bronzino
and he said I'm gonna take the burger
and the waitress asked him okay how do
you like your burger so how he likes
this burger
and do you want some cheese on your
burger and he asked is this gonna be
extra
and she says yes it's three dollars
extra and he said okay then never mind
being over there and I'm like what the
actual [__]
I'm like okay I'm hungry I'm gonna eat
my frenzy now and see what happens and
he's like oh my God you have to pay
extra for everything these days and I'm
like yeah it's New York City
so I got my Branzino he got his Burger
we were eating
and once I was satisfied I got up
and I was like I'm going to the restroom
for a second and I took my purse and I
went to the waitress and I was like hey
I just want to pay the bill
and I just paid the bill and walks out
of the restaurant and I texted him so I
texted him the check is taken care of we
should have gotten the cheese and I
blocked him so I ordered the Branzino he
had a burger and then I had the brands
you know it was delicious so I had my
friends you know and he didn't get any
cheese on us and so I after I finished
my Branzino I don't know if you guys are
aware uh but she got a branzino
I don't know why uh after you hear so
much [__] from ladies you just be
like bro you just start tuning out some
of the details and focusing on the
things that don't matter
uh what do you think about this story
and Branzino die alone and to my guy you
dodged one
I think it's perfectly fine
you know what I'm gonna tell you this
the guy doesn't want to take three
dollars for extra cheese and I
understand that cheese in general in
general is expensive I can understand
that you don't want to pay extra for
cheese three dollars actually
I think that it's a good thing I think
that it shows that no you know what I
don't need to add the cheese I'm going
to be satisfied with the burger and the
extra three dollars and you add 15 to 15
on the three dollars yeah yeah you got
money whatever whatnot I can understand
that three dollars for cheese or for an
item I can understand that you don't
want to pay that it actually shows that
you wash your money that's it but you
probably want to live lavish and have a
Branzino but all that to say I don't
think it's that big of a deal and that
makes you tune out good on you for
paying the bill that was your Flex
because you wanted to show him yeah I
show him I ain't cheap because I could
pay three dollars for cheese and I took
the Branzino did you take the brands you
know we don't know and you blocked them
for that I believe
Mental Health
therapy whatever healing you got to do
mental health he dosed one you paid for
it so that is the worst you paid for it
good on you if you would have walked out
on the date after you ate your friends
you know and not pay for your Brands you
know I would have a whole ass problem
but at least you pay for your day I
can't even be that man she paid for the
whole meal you said oh okay no cheese
for you well then no crazy for you
either check please I'm crazy let me
compensate you for your time enjoy your
burger sir and you left I don't think
he's that bad so uh yeah I do I think
it's [__] up but I still appreciate
the [__] out of you just for doing that
do you think I don't know that I'm crazy
I'm crazy
but you are taking it to a different
level
you really need to take it easy some
people going through all of my videos
commenting that I'm ugly and that I'm a
four that I'm a two that I don't deserve
love I should die alone I should delete
myself I should myself that's a bit much
that's a bit much but the way that you
start don't you know my girl
all you [__] commenting you
want accountability she's accountable
for what she did
um wait she knows she's crazy going out
of your way to call someone a four or
two whatever this and that whatever what
not true that's a bit messed up going
through all the video in this stack you
you deserve to you deserve to
self-delete yourself you want the same
bin as her it's like
don't you know I'm crazy she's like yeah
all right she she
took it yeah so I appreciate her for
that well no no you know listen there's
too many people who think they just can
say what they have and not [__] treat
it or deal with it properly and think
that's accountability no no
acknowledging you have a problem is not
enough you gotta actually do something
about your [__] problem you can't
just say I have schizophrenia and I do
what I do no no stupid you actually have
to do something to treat your [__] you
have to do something to mitigate it no
accountability I have a problem what
steps are you taking to correct that
problem it's not enough to say you're an
alcoholic that's not accountability no
that's not okay in any way why are you
taking this stupid video so seriously
I'm having a laugh about it the guy is
having a laugh about it
we're talking still and we're gonna go
on a second date like he he's he laughed
about it he's a psycho like me and we're
gonna have fun I know who this guy is
but that's an L for you bro this is
funny to me sometimes people do this
stuff where they comment these things
they tell these stories and then they
get mad what people feel any type of way
about it what okay you wanted it you got
the attention now that you got the
attention you don't like the kind of
attention is it attention that you got
unjustified not really you sound
ridiculous and unreasonable you do so
people are gonna feel some type of way
you can't be mad about that now the
folks saying off yourself or whatever
obviously that's too crazy but the rest
of it that's warranted what
I think everything back
everything I said I take it back I just
listen to that [__] like
[__] it [__] it crazy yeah I know that
I'm broke I'm a [__] student I'm an
unpaid intern I'm broke my rent is half
of my paycheck
then don't buy Branzino no then don't
take the cheese yeah I think usually
taking that dude's advice maybe you
wouldn't be so [__] goddamn broken if
you didn't order that [__] with cheese
yo I'm so sick of poor people buying for
[__] like that's outside of their
goddamn paychecks and then judging other
people for trying to save money that's
your that's the skill you should learn a
little poor ass don't get me wrong if
you love you bro that's fine there's
nothing wrong with it's not me shaming
somebody but don't be broke and then
make fun of somebody else for trying to
save money excuse me stupid you're not
trying to come out of these
circumstances you got something to learn
yeah that's not that's not your place
for to do that have you been broke yeah
I've been broke too that's not true if
that person is yeah that's not your
place that's not true you're not that
person talk about making fun of a poor
person because they want to buy Payless
shoes or whatever the [__] let them pay
for whatever they want to pay for
however you got to save your money
staying at home do whatever the [__] it
is save your money but don't be out here
I'm [__] on other people and how
they save money
God of here
I'm literally I'm broke and yeah I have
a huge credit debt and that's yeah and
I'm fine about it I'm broke and it's
gonna be okay and I make really bad
financial decisions
like
yummy
y'all want me to do with this [__] bro I
think we're good
I'm not gonna [__] about money I'm
gonna enjoy myself and I'm gonna deal
with the money later I'm not gonna be
like oh that's expensive when you go
into a wine bar and they sell a glass of
wine for 15 are you gonna [__] and be
like uh yeah I can buy a whole bottle of
wine for fifteen dollars but but that's
what she did though she's a [__] about
the money she [__] about no she [__]
about him not spending it she's
basically saying like just because I'm
broke doesn't mean I'm not gonna spend
money
this is a big old red flag when you go
to a restaurant you pay extra you're not
gonna pay like you pay in a supermarket
and she says yes it's three dollars
extra and he said okay then never mind
to be fair I had the intention of paying
21 for this burger so adding three
dollars for cheese was not [__] worth
it but thank you for paying for dinner
bye bye
21 for a burger my guy honestly 21 US
dollars for a burger honestly in New
York that's low I know it is that's what
that's what I'm saying in New York three
dollars three dollars you already have a
whole last Burger some fries you should
move on with your [__] yeah I can
understand someone said like you know
what I'm already uh I'm gonna the the
cheese is not gonna add something else
it's not gonna be that much worth it so
I can't understand you know I mean I can
understand yeah listen poor people and
young people should all have financial
literacy classes absolutely because the
way y'all be furiously talking about
spending money when you went really got
to spend the way y'all be spending on
credit is crazy to me I should have had
it's crazy to me don't get me wrong
times are tough rent is high jobs not
paying enough all these problems but
some of you [__] are doing some
Friendly Fire y'all doing some
self-inflicted gun wounds talking about
gun control no [__] you shot yourself
with that one so sorry that is a kind of
crazy thing to hear I'm broke I know I'm
broke I know I'm fine but I'ma still
spend money okay
okay I don't know about y'all but me I
hear that kind of stuff I'm like I would
never date somebody like that
somebody who's that frivolous with money
that isn't even theirs is what are you
gonna do with my money
what are you gonna do with my money what
do you mean it's her money a student
loan is not your money
credit card debt is not not your money
my digress this is just me and my like
me my financial background I could never
spend like that so that's a huge red
flag to me and everything that she said
all that other [__] to me her spending
habits is probably the biggest red flag
of all but that's me anything else you
want to say oh no let us know what you
guys said